mais quel accueille incroyable je n'ai
rien fait pour le moment à part vous
demander d'applaudir bienvenue dans
cette vidéo qui a un test de crédibilité
à base d'anecdotes vrai ou fausses avec
une personne à Godefroy s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
je t'avais repéré dans le public c'est
très cool que du soleil donc on va aller
sur scène dans quelques instants tous
les deux on va dire une anecdote vrai
ouf on a des papiers vrai faut dedans
qu'une des deux personnes sur scène qui
dira la vérité notre but à Anna et moi
c'est que à la fin de toute cette vidéo
vous votiez pour qui était la personne
en train de dire la vérité et on veut
chacun que ce soit nous qui remportions
ce test de crédibilité vous aussi vous
allez monter sur scène pour raconter des
anecdotes et là c'est l'ensemble du
public qui vous jugera en notant à la
fin vous aussi chez vous vous allez
jouer vous pouvez voter dans les
commentaires éditez votre commentaire
pour dire si vous aviez bon ou pas il
est temps Anna de venir sur scène
la plus petite lève plus les
applaudissements ils montent c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable je te laisse
piocher ton papier en prendre
connaissance le garder le manger de
mettre sur toi faire ce que tu veux
le teasing c'est que j'ai fini aux
urgences à cause d'un coup de Zidane
dans mon visage merci à tous
tu as vu comment tu as choqué les gens
ouais je sais regarde comment ils sont
très attentifs maintenant moi je vais
vous donner l'anecdote vrai du coup
puisque c'est moi qui dit la vérité donc
moi mon anecdote vrai c'est que j'ai
listé un avion dans le monde entier
grâce à un système de localisation que
j'avais laissé à l'intérieur j'aurais pu
aussi dire j'ai paumé mon iPad dans un
avion et je l'ai retrouvé comme ça
mais c'était un peu moins sexy on va
continuer en nous entraînant directement
sur vous on retourne s'asseoir on
appelle la première personne sur scène
ça marche la première personne à monter
sur scène sera Mathilde
avril 2021 donc confiné mais pas trop
moi je suis dans la restauration donc
très confiné j'ai rencontré un jeune
homme fin mars on se rencontre le
feeling passe bien trois semaines après
on est à Zanzibar pour mon anniversaire
et c'était génial et après on sait
jamais revu voilà ça fait gros teasing
mais les vacances étaient incroyables
je suis confiné je rencontre un mec je
suis à Zanzibar on se reverra plus
jamais c'était trop bien merci c'est
tout pour moi c'est incroyable avril
2020 2021
confinement
on pouvait pas voyager
c'était un des seuls pays où on pouvait
feinter il y avait pas de covid là-bas
finalement je crois qu'il avait déjà une
copine en France je me suis dit
bar C'est ça la vraie question j'ai une
amie qui est tanzanienne et on a pu un
petit peu faire comme si potentiellement
on allait bosser là-bas dans un hôtel
comment vous étiez rencontré sur un site
de rencontre de dire est-ce que vous
aviez pris une piaule chacun quand même
ou alors on avait une très grande parce
que franchement pas cher donc on avait
une énorme villa en cas d'embrouille il
y avait à peu près quatre chambres donc
en fait en gros c'est parti d'un délire
vous êtes chauffé en mode viens on va
Zanzibar
on est confiné on bosse pas on part à
Zanzibar super génial on y va pour
pouvoir prendre un avion du coup parce
que c'est une question le discours
officiel c'est on part changer de vie à
Zanzibar on quitte la France et on part
bosser à Zanzibar ils vivent là-bas
la personne suivante sera Victor s'il
vous plaît alors le titre de l'anecdote
qui est j'ai aidé en footballeur à
sortir du parking j'aime déjà beaucoup
cette anecdote alors si tu es un samedi
je crois que c'était le 23 février ils
ont eu le 13 février
très furieux
donc j'étais parti faire du shopping à
Lille avec mon père donc on compte dans
le parking on fait on fait ce qu'on
avait à faire et puis on revient
[Rires]
et puis donc on revient à la voiture et
donc là il va toujours avec devant nous
elle Ferrari noire on voit la voiture
elle fait des allers-retour comme si il
y avait un problème elle pouvait pas
sortir du coup je vais voir la personne
et je me rends compte que c'est Eden
Hazard donc Eden Hazard c'était un
joueur de Lille à l'époque et donc je
vais voir je dis suite à un souci qui
bah oui j'arrive pas à sortir ma voiture
parce que elle est trop basse et donc
comme si une sortie en colimaçon et ben
on sait qu'il a le but entre le parking
et il a eu le début de la montée il est
trop important et donc mon papa dit bah
je lui est-ce que je peux essayer et
Diana me dit bah oui pas de souci on
arrive à sortir du parking et qu'on papa
sort du éclu et donc nous remercient
deux semaines après on a un mec si on
agent qui nous donne les places pour
aller voir à l'époque c'était très bien
très très bien
il y avait pas que monumentale et tu as
dit que c'était un
en plus de d'avoir sa voiture et
anecdote qui est que la voiture il a
finalement revendu à cause de ça ah ok
avec son agent quand il vient envoyer
les places des anecdotes dans l'anecdote
exceptionnelle
Mesdames et Messieurs le hasard a
désillé maintenant maintenant nous
t'écoutons donc mon anecdote c'est que
je me suis fait cracher dessus et je
t'ai de la nourriture par un orang-outan
on veut en savoir plus c'était quand
Bella avant d'arriver au tournage c'est
très chelou tous mes après-midi il y a
quelques années dans un zoo j'étais dans
les arrières de cage un endroit grillagé
on pouvait pas s'approcher trop près
c'était une femelle orang-outan qui m'a
regardé droit dans les yeux et qui
mangeait quelque chose et elle me l'a
craché dessus son reste de trognon je
crois que c'était le crachat il m'est
arrivé quelque part par là je me
souviens plus exactement cool
Jardin des Plantes
aussi bien tu as un langage très précis
en fait pour dire primal j'étais en
arrière de cage derrière les vitres
alors que c'est les grillages c'était
une femelle orang-outan
là-bas pour le travail
oui mais pas directement d'ailleurs dans
cet endroit il y avait que des femelles
et un mâle qui était très reconnaissable
c'est quand même très précis
après les les grands primates en des
caractéristiques sexuelles primaires
assez vivant ouais ouais
moi je crois que c'est très bien hein
c'est bon ok bravo
prochaine personne ce sera mieux Scott
s'il vous plaît donc mon anecdote c'est
que j'ai dormi à plusieurs reprises pas
d'affilée dans la bibliothèque de mon
village
alors en fait donc j'étais dans un club
lecture et donc une idée que qu'un des
membres du groupe a eu c'était de si on
passait la nuit à la bibliothèque et
donc on était tous là avec des matelas
on a amené tous un truc à manger on
faisait des jeux de société le fun quoi
donc c'était pas je me fais renfermer
discrètement en cachant dans les
toilettes et en disant mes pouces bleus
vidéo non il va pas du tout
dans la Drôme c'est faux c'est faux ça
n'existait pas la Drôme
et la bibliothèque elle était ouverte
tout le temps du coup quand on était
dedans on l'a fermé à clé pour éviter
que d'autres personnes rentrent dedans
quoi
5 ou 6 je pense moi je me dis c'est
peut-être tu vois ça paraît tellement
facile du coup tu te dis c'est vrai si
elle se trouve il nous Braine en
racontant un truc pas si dingue tu vois
Scott c'est bien noté ne te remercions
pour ton anecdote merci Scott la
personne suivante si elle veut déjà se
préparer mentalement et nous rejoindre
ce sera Nathalie je faisais mes études
aux Conservatoire il y avait un petit
jeune qui devait donner une réplique en
fait il était tellement mort de trac au
lieu de chanter des trucs qu'il avait à
chanter il les a mis mais c'était un
examen qu'on passait en fin d'année
d'art lyrics on avait un gars qui devait
donner une réplique moi je chantais dans
le truc aussi enfin on était quatre sur
cette petite scène et on a pris un petit
jeune donc c'était la première année de
chant là il y avait un mec qui lui
demandait comment allez-vous le soldat
et le Hitler répondent je suis encore un
peu souffrant et en fait il a pas
répondu et le gars il a fait
je pleurais j'ai pas pu chanter la fin
alors c'était pas moi qui c'était pas en
fait on était quatre à passer enfin il y
avait quatre personnes sur la scène
n'ont donné des répliques en fait et tu
chantes toujours aujourd'hui ah oui oui
c'est mon métier
il vous reste deux personnes à faire
passer à la questionnaire je propose de
commencer par Anna alors je commence par
le début donc on ne connaît plus sous le
nom de Anna Godefroy mais mon vrai nom
c'est Anaëlle Godefroy quivache d'hiver
c'est le nom de ma mère et Givart c'est
le nom aussi d'un joueur de foot
Stéphane Givart champion du monde 98
l'anecdote espace en 2008 donc en gros
il voulait faire une espèce de réunion
les 10 ans champion du monde tout ça et
moi mon oncle en fait il a une maison à
Trégunc en Bretagne une grande propriété
donc ils ont fait ça là-bas c'était pas
du tout un truc officiel c'était
vraiment comme si vous faisiez un
barbecue entre amis sauf que bah là il y
avait des champions du monde quoi et du
coup il y a il y a un repas avec tout le
monde et après ils se disent bon on va
faire un petit un petit foot dans le
jardin de stéphane et moi ce moment-là
donc j'ai 10 ans j'ai envie de
participer donc je sais pas la meilleure
idée que j'ai je me lance sauf que
mauvais timing je me retrouve à côté de
Zidane qui était vraiment dans le jardin
avec le ballon il tape et je me prends
son tibia en pleine face donc je tombe
j'avais mes lunettes j'ai une petite
cicatrice sur le nez vous pouvez pas
voir là mais j'ai une toute petite
cicatrice ici et en fait mais on RIP sur
mon nez donc j'étais en sang donc je me
suis retrouvé dans une voiture avec ma
mère mon oncle Zidane on arrive aux
urgences et donc les mecs des urgences
s'ils ont pas compris ce qui se fait moi
j'étais dans les choux donc je me
rappelle plus trop du moment exact au
final j'avais pas grand chose j'ai eu
trois points de suture je suis ressorti
et j'ai fait une petite photo avec
Zidane et il m'a même envoyé après un
maillot dédicacé ce qui était tellement
désolé que voilà moi je peux rien
commenter puisque forcément je sais donc
je vous laisse poser vos questions à
Anna
[Musique]
une grande propriété en Bretagne il a
lancé l'invite moi je me suis incrustée
du coup il y avait Lilian Thuram il y
avait Lizarazu Deschamps après le reste
j'avais 10 ans et moi alors moi vraiment
en foot si vous voulez me cuisiner
là-dessus là je connais rien donc mais
bon il y avait des champions quoi donc
ouais enfin ils sont quand même
légendaires
il y en a qui étaient là je sais pas qui
c'est et là du coup tu as quel âge là
j'ai 24 ans
à tréguin dans le Finistère numéro de
département 29
j'étais moi j'ai couru en fait enfin
j'étais je voulais jouer
ta cicatrice de Zizou ou quoi non c'est
cool en même temps après je me souviens
pas du moment exact parce qu'après
j'étais dans les choux mais
moi j'avais pas trouvé d'intitulé parce
que parce que quand on vit des
événements dans sa vie on cherche pas à
leur donner un intitulé quand c'est vrai
donc en gros je donne le contexte je
vais sur l'île de Saint-Martin parce que
j'ai un ami qui habite là-bas etc
j'arrive en avion je sors les les
affaires de la valise tout ça en haut et
c'est vraiment à la sortie de l'aéroport
que je sais plus jusque je cherche ou
pourquoi parce que j'en ai pas besoin je
me rends compte que j'ai pu mon iPad
donc en fait je me rends compte très
très vite je file dans l'aéroport je
vais prévenir le guichet Air France etc
pour qui qui fasse le nécessaire on fait
poireauter 1000 ans et on me dit que
quelqu'un va regarder qu'il faut que je
laisse mes coordonnées et que je m'en
aille d'ici et c'est très dur de partir
quand tu sais que l'avion est encore là
tu sais c'est sûr que l'iPad tu l'as
laissé dedans mais voilà direction du
coup le tel parce qu'à un moment donné
on va pas rester dans l'aéroport toute
sa vie arrivé à l'hôtel du coup une fois
là-bas sur place me vient une idée parce
que c'est pas du tout confiance dans les
gens que j'ai vu à l'aéroport c'est
quand on te dit oui non mais c'est bon
on va le marché donnez-nous un numéro
voilà allez suivant je me dis mais j'ai
activé le service géolocalisé sur mon
iPad donc je peux regarder depuis mon
ordinateur ou mon iphone ou est-ce qu'il
est et donc je vois effectivement mon
iPad étape uni par Charles de Gaulle
donc je le revois partir à de Gaulle ce
qui est plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour
moi parce que je me dis donc il est bien
dans l'avion ça c'est parce que encore
une fois j'étais pas si sûr de moi
entre-temps j'avais vu qu'il était bien
à l'aéroport de Juliana à Saint-Martin
je dis c'est bon ils vont le trouver
après je le vois partir je me disais ils
n'ont pas trouvé sauf que moi je vois
mon iPad partir en Russie après la
Russie je le vois partir à Abidjan et
après je le revois je le reverrai mais
plus tard partir à Charles de Gaulle et
du coup moi je pèse un peu et je veux
pas faire le relou ni auprès de la
directrice de l'hôtel ni auprès du
contact qu'elle m'a donné du chef de
cabine tu sens bien que tu abuses tu es
déjà privilégié de d'avoir des points de
contact direct et en même temps j'ai un
tracé d'avion quoi et du coup je renvoie
un mail au gars je vous passe un peu les
étapes où j'explique il fait non non
c'est sur il était pas je dis mais moi
je suis capable de vous donner tout le
tracé de vol de cet appareil sur ses 72
dernières heures et lui en fait m'a
répondu un truc un peu en mode ok là
c'est très grave parce qu'on a un vrai
problème de sécurité donc ils ont fait
des fouilles approfondie un jour et
apparemment ils ont trouvé un truc
improbable dans lequel qui pouvait se
glisser mais on est en direct carlingue
ça pur rapport avec le siège donc c'est
pas ce qui s'est passé j'ai ouvert mon
sac je pense que l'iPad a sauter de
lui-même il a rampé vers la pire cache
possible en se disant on ne trouvera
jamais et voilà et donc par la méthode
c'est une vraie faille de sécurité voilà
je pense que vous avez pas de question
c'était très crédible
absolument dans les trains d'habitude
ça arrive plusieurs fois oui bah oui bah
apparemment il va falloir que je fasse
gaffe à mes affaires mais pour l'instant
tout ce que je perds je le retrouve
ah non les avions ça volent un avion au
sol ça coûte très cher donc ils le font
repartir très vite
je trouve marrant cette phrase parce que
on s'est dit d'avion pour l'avion alors
le mode avion il sert aujourd'hui au
décollage de l'appareil à l'atterrissage
pour pas perturber les instruments de
bord avant c'était le cas ça fait je
crois au moins trois quatre ans qu'on
nous demande plus forcément de le mettre
durant le vol en fait
elle était dans mon sac à dos et comme
je l'avais pas sorti j'ai pas cherché
l'iPad qui aurait pu traîner
non ça crédit
voter en votre année conscience et Anna
rejoint moi
vous devez dire qui de Anna ou moi dit
la vérité ok donc vous pouvez mettre les
deux prénoms si vous voulez mais il y a
forcément un ou deux qui ment en
l'occurrence il y a nous deux qui dit la
vérité sincèrement car il ne ment jamais
c'est moi mais mon autre anecdote était
très très bien aussi on fait juste le
teaser de notre deuxième anecdote ok
c'était j'ai piloté il aurait fallu
affiner mais j'ai piloté un gros énorme
bateau de croisière dans le canal de
Corinthe pas mal et toi c'était quoi ta
deuxième moi ce serait que Emma Watson
m'a embrassé sur la joue et m'a envoyé
du courrier chez moi à Cholet
je connais du beau monde est-ce que vous
avez fait vos votes on va d'abord
vérifier pour les quatre personnes qui
sont montées sur scène je vais demander
à Manon de nous dire si elle mentait ou
si elle disait la vérité Manon c'est
vrai c'est vrai vérité alors tu avais
une bonne crédibilité on était sur une
majorité de vrai il y avait beaucoup
d'introspection c'est à dire son elle ne
regardait pas franchement les yeux dès
qu'elle cherchait un détail elle se
mettait sur le côté et il y avait
beaucoup de flou ce qui est plutôt
cohérent quand tu racontes une anecdote
tu te souviens pas forcément de tout
très précisément dans les détails quand
tu mens c'est facile de les inventer
pour combler donc on avait ces deux
choses là pour toi donc c'était pas mal
bonne crédibilité tu as tu avais mis
vrai aussi pour Manon et on a mis vrai
aussi tous les deux pour Scott Scott
est-ce que c'était vrai c'était vrai
Scott incroyable il est allé dormir la
bibliothèque avec l'autorisation de tout
le monde encadré d'accompagnants et
c'était vrai incroyable
c'était alors que nous on était à non
c'est impossible qui avait mis faux
assumer
ils sont dit c'est trop il est en train
de nous brain en fait c'est sûr c'est
sûr pour Nathan j'ai mis faux pour Nath
moi j'ai mis faux aussi pour Nath
les seuls éléments de crédibilité que
j'avais c'était quand tu racontais
l'histoire qui se déroulait sur scène où
je suis non mais là elle est pas en
train de réinventer toute l'histoire là
du gars où ça aussi tu l'as inventé ah
ouais c'était super crédible
à la fac en même temps et tu as dit fin
juin pas du tout fin avril la fac
vraiment il y a des vacances Victor t'as
mis vraiment
il y a des problèmes de temps pour aller
oui
on voit que tu connais la détection de
mensonge parce que essayer de nous
mettre des fausses pistes genre les
détails inutiles genre attends non je me
suis trompé c'était le jour etc qui est
plutôt crédible et le et le dans les
yeux tout le temps qui est plutôt un
symbole de mensonge parce que t'as pas
besoin de te rappeler vraiment du truc
tu veux vraiment convaincre donc tu
captes le truc quoi je fais c'est
d'accord c'est bien joué et retourner
les ardoises là pour les derniers ne dis
rien Nathalie pour l'instant eh Nathan
Nathalie on a un peu tout moi j'ai mis
vrai toi tu as mis vrai pour moi j'ai
envie d'y croire
oh là là jolie levez la main ceux qui
ont mis faux ah ouais non tu nous as tu
nous apprennes c'est maintenant que vous
devez voter lever la main les personnes
qui pensent qu'Anna dit la vérité alors
une deux trois quatre cinq six sept huit
neufs 11 12 13 très beau taux de
crédibilité
qui pense que jeudi la vérité puisque je
dis la vérité 4 mais de qualité moi
alors
déjà quoi qu'il arrive tu as gagné cette
vidéo ok puisque le but c'était c'était
d'être le plus crédible possible donc tu
as été beaucoup plus crédible que moi
très à 14 je veux dire là il y a pas
photo je m'inquiète
est-ce qu'on leur dit genre pas
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt Ciao
non mais mon somme c'est d'avoir perdu
peu importe si vous avez raison aussi
j'ai bien perdu tu peux leur avouer si
tu disais la vérité aussi tu m'entends
d'accord mon nom est bien Anaëlle
Godefroy qui marche
[Musique]
j'ai aucun rapport avec Stéphane voilà
bravo quoi
la cicatrice j'ai plongé dans une
piscine je suis remontée je me suis
éclaté le nez
parce que moi qui savais que c'était
faux en vrai j'avais envie de voter pour
toi moi aussi tu vois je savais que tu
racontais un truc faux et j'étais vrai
c'est sûr j'ai fait un foot avec Zidane
dans mon jardin pourquoi pas il a bien
dormi dans une bibliothèque avec une
autorisation tout est possible dans
cette vidéo je profite de sourire
générale pour vous dire penser
évidemment à vous abonner à cette chaîne
Youtube merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo dans la description vous avez un
lien plusieurs liens vers les réseaux de
Anna Godefroy merci beaucoup d'être venu
tant de cette vidéo on avait très envie
de faire des vidéos ensemble et on en
fera sûrement d'autres quand je le somme
sera digéré si de 3 ans si vous voulez
participer à mes vidéos rappelez-vous il
y a un lien dans la description pour
vous inscrire si vous voulez qu'on se
croise en dehors des vidéos venez me
voir un spectacle quand tu vas pendant
le spectacle après prenez soin de vous à
très bientôt Ciao
[Applaudissements]